one of my
direct subordinates one of my guys that
worked for me he would he would call me
up or pull me aside with some major
problems some issue that was going on
and he'd say awesome we got this and
that and the other thing and i'd look at
him and i'd say
good and finally one day he was telling
me about some issue that he was having
some problem and
he said i already know what you're gonna
say
i said well what am i gonna say he said
you're gonna say
[Music]
good said that's what you always say
when something is wrong and going bad
you always just look at me and say good
and i said well yeah
when
things are going bad
there's gonna be some good
that's gonna come from it
didn't get the new high-speed gear we
wanted
good
didn't get promoted
good
more time to get better
oh mission got cancelled
good we can focus on another one didn't
get funded didn't get the job you wanted
got injured
sprained my ankle got tapped out good
got beat
good
unexpected problems
good
we have the opportunity
to figure out a solution
[Music]
that's it
when things are going bad
don't get all bummed out don't get
startled don't get frustrated
[Music]
if you can say the word good
guess what
it means you're still alive
it means you're still breathing
and if you're still breathing
well now
you still got some fight left in you
so get up
[Music]
dust off
reload
recalibrate
re-engage
and go out on the attack
[Music]